for the last few lectures we've been
talking about the extremal problem of
forbidding a complete bipartite graph so
today i want to move beyond the complete
bipartite graph and look at other
sparser bipartite graphs so we'll be
looking at what happens to the extremal
problem if you forbid a sparse bipartite
graph
recall the khawarij shows Tyrande room
which tells you that the extremal number
for KS piece is upper bounded by
something on the order of n to the 2
minus 1 over s so if I give you some
bipartite H we know that because it's a
bipartite graph it is always contained
in some KST for some values of s and P
so you already automatically have an
upper bound the extremal number for this
H from the khawarij shorter on 0 but as
you might expect we might be very
wasteful in this step and the question
is are there situations where we can do
much better than what is just given by
applying Cavazos to Ron and today I want
to show you several examples where you
can significantly improve the bound
given by Cavazos Terron for various
sparser bipartite graphs so the first
result is the following theorem which is
initially due to parody and then a later
different proof was given by a long
curve elevation surah kahf and
the larger proof is the one that I want
to present because it presents an
important and intricate probabilistic
technique which is the main reason for
showing you this theorem but let me tell
you the theorem first here H will be a
bipartite graph and it has vertex by
partitions a and B such that every
vertex in a has degree at most R by
partition is a and P and the degree in a
is at most R for every vertex on the
left on the left side in the set a and I
want to understand is there some upper
bound on the extremal number that thus
better than kovash shows Turan and the
theorem guarantees such a pound so then
there exists some constant depending on
H such that the extremal member is or
propounded by something to the order of
n to the 2 minus 1 over R compared with
Co very shows tour on on one hand if you
H is the complete bipartite graph KST
then this is the same bound as co-vary
shorter on on the other hand you might
have a lot more vertices in a and a lot
more vertices in B the hypothesis only
says only requires that the degreasing a
max degree is at most R so it could be a
much bigger graph so if you apply cavora
shows Torah you would get a much worse
bound compared to what this theorem
guarantees ok
this one of ours optimal you cannot in
this given statement you cannot improve
this one of our right because we know
that from the KST example and the lower
bounds I showed you last time you cannot
improve upon this one over R so in this
form this theorem is best possible what
tip I want to show you a probabilistic
technique for proving this theorem and
it is an important idea called dependent
random choice okay so let me first give
you an informal interpretation that
what's going on so the idea is that if
you have a graph G with many edges then
inside G I can find a large subset of
vertices u such that all small subsets
of vertices in u many common neighbors
because I won't tell you what this small
and many yard are just yet so we'll see
it through the proof of the theorem but
that's the idea so I give you a graph
it's not too sparse it's relatively
dense then I should be able to find a
some subset that is fairly large so that
lets say every pair of vertices in the
subset has many common neighbors so let
me write down or these attempt to write
down a formal statement dependent random
choice the statement of the theorem is
our wall present has a lot of parameters
but don't get I don't want to be scared
off by the parameter so I won't even
tell you what they are but first tell
you what the statement of the conclusion
is and then won't arrive
what is the dependencies on the
parameters through the proof write the
technique is much more important than
the statement of the theorem itself
leave some space here the conclusion is
that every graph with n vertices and at
least alpha and squared over 2 edges
contains a subset U of vertices U is not
to smoke so u the size of us at least
little U and such that for every subset
s of U with our elements the set s has
at least M common neighbors
all right so what's the idea here I give
you this graph and I want you to produce
this set u that has this property how
many go about finding this said you let
me give you an analogy I suppose you
have the friendship graph on MIT campus
and I want to select a large set I say a
hundred students such that every pair of
them or maybe even just most pairs of
them have many common friends how might
you go about doing that well if you
select a hundred students at random
you're unlikely to achieve that outcome
they're going to be pretty dispersed
across campus but if you focus on some
commonalities so for example you go to
someone some specific individual and
look at their circle of close friends
then it seems more likely you will be
able to identify a group of people who
are very well connected in that their
pairwise have lots of common friends and
that's the idea here we're going to make
the random choice by picking that core
individual that's the random choice but
then make the subsequent dependent
random choice by looking at the group of
friends from that specific random
individual instead of choosing the
hundred people uniformly I ran them
which is not going to work all right so
let's execute that strategy on this
graph let me take T to be the random set
so that's the core set so let P be from
convenience I'm going to choose with
repetition so instead of just choosing
one person I'm going to choose T
vertices so unless key vertices chosen
uniformly at random
from Bieber Tech set and what we are
going to do is look at the set ape which
is the set of common neighbors the
vertices that are adjacent to all of T
and that's the set I want to think about
right so I want you basically argue that
this set a has more or less the
properties that we desire maybe with
some small number of blemishes which we
will fix by cleaning up first I want to
guarantee that a has a big size we are
actually choosing a lot of vertices so
let's evaluate the size of a in
expectation by linearity of expectation
we need to compute the sum of the
probabilities that individual vertices
fall in this random a for each
particular vertex a when for each
particular vertex V when it's a name a
but it is in a if P is contained in the
neighborhood of this V right so all of
your chosen piece fall into the
neighborhood otherwise V is not going to
be contained so each individual
probability can be computed easily by
looking at the size to the degree of the
divided by the number of vertices raised
to the power T P independent choices
chosen with replacement and by convexity
apply to the final expression we find
that it is at least this quantity here
where essentially we're taking the
averages of the degrees so this is by
convexity and finally the graph has at
least that many edges so the final
quantity there is at least and alpha to
the T it's question there's questions in
our original list are we allowed to have
repeated vertices yes so it's a list and
we're choosing every element
independently at random allowing
repetition so it's sometimes called
choosing with replacement you choose a
tee you throw it back which is another
one all right the property that we're
looking for except for every s subset
for every our element subset of U it has
many common neighbors so let's look at
such an S so for each S which is an
element subset of the vertex set so
subset of B what is the probability that
this set s is contained in a so I'll
give you this set s it is contained in a
if well let's think about how a is
chosen you have you want mr. huttle and
a is chosen as a common neighborhood of
this team so s is containing a if and
only if t is contained in the common
neighborhood
yes actual X is fixed for now P is
random so we draw the elements of T
independently uniformly at random
therefore this probability is equal to
the number of common neighbors of this
as a fraction of the total number of
vertices this fraction raised to the
power T we want all S sub subsets of a
all our element subsets of this a to
have at least M common neighbors but
maybe we cannot get that so let's figure
out how many bad asses are there how
many asses do not satisfy this condition
here so let's call such a set s bad if
it has fewer than M common neighbors and
from this equation we see that for each
fixed s that is our element subset of
vertices it is bad with probability well
it is bad if as few common neighbors or
as few common neighbors then this
probability is small so it is bad with
probability strictly less than M over N
raised to the power T
so we chose this a in this dependent
random way and basically we wonder all
subsets are element subsets have many
common neighbors but maybe we cannot get
that at the first try but we only have a
small number of blemishes so we can fix
those blemishes by getting rid of the
possible paths or subsist and that's
fine to do as long as they're not too
many of them and indeed because each s
is bad with small probability the
expected number of paths are element
subsets a is at most well I look over
all possible are elements subsets of
vertices each one of them is bad with
this probability here so we have that
bound and the point now is that if this
number is significantly smaller than the
expected size of a then I can clean up
all the bad subsets by plucking out one
vertex from each bad subset so indeed
that is the case because the expectation
of the size of a minus so let me call
this quantity here start so the size of
a - start by what we have shown is at
least and our path to the t minus the
quantity just now and I want this number
to be somewhat large and now let me put
that as a hypothesis
[Applause]
depending random choice Matt you and our
G+ integers alpha positive real and
suppose and alpha to the T - and choose
R and W all right that's where that
inequality comes from if this is at
least company then what we can do is the
lead one vertex from each path subset
each path subset s and after deleting a
then becomes some smaller set a prime
with at least new elements in
expectation but then there exists put it
this way we know that this is true in
expectation so thus there exists some T
such that that inequality is true
without the expectation so there exist
some T such that this quantity is at
least that so now to be the vertex from
each path subset we obtain this a prime
with at least new elements and we have
gotten rid of all the possible paths
subsets
but our element subsets and that
finishes off we prove of dependent
random choice just a recap the idea is
that if you have a large if you have a
dense enough graph then I want to find
the conclusions that you can find a
fairly large subset of vertices so that
every small subset so every pair every
element have many common neighbors and
the way you do this instead of choosing
your set I random which is not going to
work you choose a small set of anchors t
you think of that as the anchors you
choose a bunch of anchors and then you
look at their common neighborhoods and
use that as a starting point will almost
work it might not work perfectly but
then you fix things up by removing the
blemishes okay so this is a very tricky
probabilistic idea is it's also a very
important one it will allow us to prove
the theorem over there about the
extremal members of bounded degree
graphs question
question is in the definition of path do
I use this definition for all subsets of
B all are element subsets or just subset
of a so I used it to mean all subsets of
V because a is random where a is random
so I so the definition of path does not
depend on the randomness only depends on
the original graph
the badness does not - because how does
the badness depend on any probability
badness does not depend on a probability
but a is random so the number of paths
are element subsets of a is a random
variable so each individual so you start
with a graph some elements subsets are
bad some are not and now I choose this
random a in this dependent random manner
and a might contain some that subsets
I'm trying to calculate how many grand
how many bad subsets this a question to
each okay so your concerns each s is bad
with probability ah sorry fine
yeah thank you so each so I define great
so each bad subset okay so for each
fixed subset it is contained I hope this
makes it clear so the probability of the
property of being bad it's not random
but it been containing a is random
question
ah okay so question is why is this true
so why are these two events the same and
you kind of had to steer the definition
a bit so he is chosen as the common
neighborhoods so you choose ta random
and choose a to be the common
neighborhood a peak and so when you how
do you characterize subsets of a if
every element is connected to all of let
you think about it any more questions
yes we picked here random even if key is
uniform there's no questions how are we
picking key key is uniform I render ah
great so questions how do we pick the
little ping the theorem statement it
depends on the application it is a
little bit weird because in the app in
this statement of the theorem that
little piece shows up in inequality but
not in the conclusion so you think of T
as an auxilary
parameter so the little T comes up in
the proof but not really in the
conclusion any more questions it's a
tricky lemma it's a tricky idea so now
let me use it to prove the statement
over there and here is it's not so hard
so it's mostly an application of this
dependent random choice lemma for H as
in theorem so let me prove this lemma so
for all HS in the theorem there exists a
constant C such that every graph well at
least C and to the two minus one over
our edges contains a vertex
you with sober tax upset you with the
size of you equal to P so P comes from
the vertex by partition of H it's a
constant such that every our element
subset in P haviar elements upsetting
you has lots of common neighbors at
least another constant which is the
number of vertices in H that many common
neighbors you see it's a direct
corollary of the dependent random choice
lemma by setting in the right parameters
and indeed by the dependent random
choice lemma where we choose this T this
auxiliary variable T in P independent
random choice lemma two equal to R so
suffices to check that there exists at C
such that well plug it into that
expression that inequality up there so
and to see and to the minus 1 over R
raised to the power R minus and choose R
and then this expression here okay so
I'm just plugging in the various graph
parameters into the dependent random
choice statement and I want to show that
you can find a constant C such that this
inequality is true and indeed these
exponents they cancel out so the first
term is simply to see raised to the our
and the second one because again you
notice that the exponents work out just
fine so it is a constant at most a
constant so you can choose C big enough
so that this is true so so direct
verification of the hypothesis of the
lemma and now we're ready to prove the
theorem over there so the question is
how do you have size of a plus B comma
neighbor so H is fixed and a and B are
constants a plus B is the size of the
number of vertices of H that's a
constant so yeah I'm talking about
common neighbors not in H budding the
big graph G has n vertices okay now I
like questions so this is it's tricky
it's a tricky argument so please do ask
questions if you're confused and there
are times when I may not have explained
it very well so please do ask questions
so let's prove the theorem and now we're
almost there the ideas are we embed the
vertices of B into the big Rajee one by
one
so first embed B into the vertices of G
using new from the lemma we just stated
and I claim that once you have done that
to the vertices of feet and now I need
to embed the remaining vertices okay
and I can do this one by one because if
I need to impact some vertex of eight a
has and most are neighbors to be but
I've embedded B in such a way that they
have a lot of common neighbors inside G
so I can always do right I can always
embed the vertices of a one at a time in
such a way that I even avoid collisions
I don't allow vertices to embed it into
the same place this is all using that be
that embedding a P which is U has many
common neighbors in G so once you put
that in and the rest just make one
choice at a time and you need to better
second vertex or you can find somewhere
in their common neighborhood that allows
you could do it
so embed the vertices one at a time and
then you finish embedding the whole
graph any questions it's a tricky
argument so let's take a break and I
want you to think about it okay any
questions
or some questions how do you embed a
without having any collisions so I
putting the vertices at B so that every
R of them have many neighbors and now I
want to try to embed the vertices of a
one by one any water okay think about
you pick the first vertex where can I go
it has that says adjacent to the first
three vertices of B so in the embedding
it has to go in the common neighborhood
of those three vertices which we know is
large so I put them anywhere and I do
the same for the second vertex do the
same for the fourth vertex so I just
keep on going because the common
neighborhood is large it may be that
some of the potential vertices I might
embed is already used by the previous
steps in the process but because I
always have at least a plus B common
neighbors I always have some
possibilities that remain
yes question
ah the questions how there's this path
subset deletion work so you have this a
which is fairly large and you know that
there exist some instance there's some
instance of this randomness that
produces for you a situation where a has
very few bad or subsets so then I take a
and I delete from a one vertex in each
bad subset I haven't changed the size of
a very much a is still quite large
after this division but now a has no bad
subsets remaining because I've gotten
rid of one vertex from each one from
each bad subset so very similar to what
we've seen before the random process for
creating an H free graph now you
generate a random H free graph which has
very few copies of H relative to the
number of edges and then you get rid of
them by removing one edge from each copy
of H okay so with the theorem that we
saw in the first part of the lecture we
saw how to improve on the boundary
coverage shows Terron in some
circumstances namely one where the graph
that you're forbidding this h
essentially has found the degree so we
stated something a bit stronger namely
has found the degree from one side and
that's that's a really general result
and now I want you to look at some more
specific situations where you might be
able to improve further so what are some
nice bipartite graphs one that comes up
is kind of even cycles C 4 C 6 and so on
and you see C 4 is the same as K 2 2
which we already saw before but even C 6
the technique so far allow us to obtain
with the theorem that we just saw gives
us a bound on c6 that's more or less the
same as that of C 4 namely n to the
three-halves
so what's the truth for seasick
so it turns out that you can do much
better so this is the theorem of foam be
romanovitch that for all integers okay
at least two they exist some constant C
such that the extremal number you see
too many times so I'll just say that the
extremal number of C 2 sub K is at most
on the order of n to the 1 plus 1 over K
so in particular for 6 cycles the upper
bound is 4/3 in the exponent better than
the three-halves so this is another
class of graphs where there are some
nice upper bounds that you can ask what
just like cove are we chose to run for
complete bipartite graphs do we know
matching lower bound constructions and
what is known is that it is tight only
for a small number of cases and the
others we do not know whether they're
tight so responding Shimoda mesh theorem
it is trade for k being 2 3 or 5 and
opening for others so they are
constructions for c for free
c 6 free and C 10 free but not for CH
freak that's an open problem
the proof of the bounty romanovitch
theorem is slightly involved but I want
to show you a weaker result that already
contains a lot of interesting ideas so a
weak weaker result is this that for
every integer okay at least two there
exists a constant C such that every end
vertex graph G well at least C so this
the correct the same water number just
okay so that we don't for boning some
other fish it contains an even cycle of
length exactly 2k
okay so we'll show something is slightly
weaker that contains an even cycle of
length and most qk which in other words
says that the extremal number if you so
we haven't introduced this notation but
hopefully you can guess what it means
that if you forbid all of these cycles
then it is this quantity so I'll show
this weaker result
all right let's do it first I want to
show you a couple of easy preparatory
lemmas first every graph G contains a
sub graph with min degree at least half
at least half of the average degree of G
so you have a graph G it has large
average degree has lots of edges but
maybe there are some small degree
vertices and it will be useful to know
that the minimum degree is actually
quite large as well so it turns out by
passing to a sub graph you can guarantee
that how do you think we might prove
this give you a graph I know it has lots
of edges but maybe some vertices a small
degree yep
okay so you suggest depending random
choice that's a heavy hammer for such a
simple statement so it turns out we can
do something even simpler so we just
throw out the minute that we vertices
throw out the small degree vertices if
the average degree is two T then the
number of edges is number of vertices
times key and you see that removing a
vertex of the green key for most key
cannot decrease average degree so I have
this process where I remove vertices
that are less than half of average
degree and the average degree never go
step so I keep on doing this average
degree stays the same well you can't go
up but it never goes down and when I
stop I don't have any more small degree
vertices to get rid of so why does this
process even terminate maybe we end up
with the empty graph which is not so
useful yes
you said the average degree is
non-decreasing but how do I know the
graph has at least some number of
vertices when I stop yes
okay so if you you must terminate you
must terminate because every graph if
you have way too small number of
vertices because for example if just
notice that every graph Worth and most
to three vertices has average degree
less than 2 T so you'll never get below
two T vertices you run out of the room
if you go too far because that's the
first preparation I'm on a second one is
that every graph G has a bipartite sub
graph with at least half of a number of
edges as the original graph okay this is
a very nice and quick exercise in the
probabilistic method so we can color
every vertex black and white uniformly
at random and the expected number of
black to white edges is exactly half of
the original number of edges by the
narrative expectations so there are some
instance with at least that many black
white edges and that's a bipartite graph
ok so now we can prove the theorem about
even cycles the weaker theorem at least
I start with a graph which has a lot of
edges but by these two lemmas and
changing constant somewhat I can obtain
a sub graph with that's bipartite and
has min degree quite large so I lose a
most a constant factor and I get
basically within a factor of two factor
four of the average degree okay so let
me call this quantity Delta the min
degree in this sub graph is bipartite
graph let's think about what happens to
this graph if I start with an arbitrary
vertex so now I have a min degree
condition it's the old vertices are now
kind of the same to me to pick an
arbitrary vertex and look at its
neighborhood it has at least Delta edges
coming out so let me call the first
vertex level zero and the second set
level one it's bipartite so there are no
edges within level one let's expand out
even further
okay
can there be some collisions where two
of these edges go to the same works well
if there were then I find a c4 so if I
assume there's no c4 c6 and so on C C to
K for contradiction so because there's
no c4 all the end points of these paths
of length two are distinct in level two
and you keep going where you keep
expanding further and so on and all the
way to level P and all of these guys
must be distinct as well because
otherwise you find a cycle of length and
most two T so we do this expansion each
step you can't distinct vertices and you
also have no I just
inside each part because you're looking
in the bipartite setting okay so how
many vertices do you get at the end well
I haven't min degree condition the min
degree condition tells me that I expand
by a factor of at least Delta minus one
each time so the number of vertices in
here it's at least Delta minus 1 raised
to the power T so raise the power K
here's K I expand all the way to the end
but you see that number there it's quite
large so in particular if C is large
enough then it's bigger than
and that would be a contradiction
because you only had and vertices in the
graph to begin with therefore the
assumption that there are no cycles even
cycles of length at most 2k is incorrect
and that finishes the proof any
questions so questions has to do with in
the original in the four ponies from one
of its theorem so what we need to do are
they similar so certainly you want to do
something like this but then you also
want to think about if you do have short
cycles how can you bypass them right so
there's more careful analysis of what
happens with shorter cycles and we will
not get into that
any more questions all right so the
first term that we did in today's
lecture has to do with what okay so
questions why the vertices distinct for
level K so at level K if you had some
collapse then it came from two different
paths
therefore forming a cqk okay
so now I want to revisit the first
theorem that happened in today's lecture
namely if you have this age bipartite a
and B so we saw the hypothesis was that
if every vertex in a had found the
degree degree at most R then we got an
upper bound on extrema number that was n
to the 2 minus 1 over R in particular
for R equals to 2 suppose that situation
their degree every vertex in a is at
most 2 then the first theorem guaranteed
us that the extremal number is on the
order at most n to the 3 halves just
like the extremal number for 4 cycles
for k2 T's and of course this statement
is tight in the sense that if I change
the 3 half to any smaller number than
just taking H to be K 2 2 violation so I
cannot replace in this generality 3
halves by any smaller number because we
know that the extremal number 4 K 2 2 is
disorder but is that the only
obstruction so if H is not K 2 2 you can
make some studio examples to by taking K
2 2 and add some more edges so let's
forbid H from having a K 2 2 sub graph
can you do better now in this case can
you improve for the specific age that
exponent and we already saw one case
where you can do this right so namely in
Bonnie's one of edge theorem or cycles
if you only apply to this theorem here
you get 3 half but Bonnie's semenovich
tells you a much better exponent
so so let's explore this situation and
it turns out in a very recent theorem
it's only proved in the last couple of
years my David :
and Jim Comey they showed that for every
H as above there exists constants little
C and Big C such that the extremal
number of H is upper bounded by
something where I can decrease
three-halves to some even smaller number
so somehow this three-halves
now we understand it's really because of
the presence of K to 2 the graph has if
H has no K 2 2 then some smaller number
surprises and I want to use the rest of
today to explain how to prove that
theorem there it's question that's right
so the question is okay see the
independent of H so C depends on C
they're dependent
questions let me put this question in a
slightly different formulation that is
also equivalent so in graph theory there
is a notion of a subdivision and in
particular a one subdivision of graph H
it's this operation where you start with
a graph let's say this graph here and
you add a vertex to the middle of every
edge of the square initially it's four
vertices now you add a new vertex to
every edge so you stop the bike every
edge into a path of two edges that's
called a subdivision so for today's
lecture let me to note subdivisions by a
prime in particular if this is a fourth
and I want to know this graph here k4
prime so for example hey V prime so
that's a triangle subdivided c66
so observe that every age that comes up
in this theorem here there's a subgraph
some subdivision someone subdivision of
a creek because the vertices on the left
in a of degree 2 so you think of them as
midpoints of edges but because you are K
2 2 3 you if you collapse those paths of
length 2 2 single edges you do not end
up with parallel edges so it has the sub
graph of this one subdivision of some
graph which then you can complete to a
clique okay so this theorem here is
equivalent I leave qualitatively to the
statement that for every P there exists
some constants again depending on P such
that the extremal number of the one
subdivision of a clique is bounded by
something where we can improve upon the
exponent in the first theorem in today's
lecture
so that doom there so these two terms
are you covenant because of this remark
any questions so far about the
statements how do you deal with vertices
with degree less than two completed to a
vertex degree of vertex of degree two
add another edge add another edge to a
new vertex any more questions all right
so the proof I want to show you is due
to all over again sir and for this click
subdivision theorem and this proof
produces the C sub T equals to one over
40 minus six so if you plug in T equals
to three you find that the exponent here
it's actually height for the six cycle
actually agrees with what we know
okay so I want to show you some of the
main ideas from this truth just like the
proof of that we saw for the psychos
Stephen cycles theorem it will be
helpful to start with some preparation
you start with a graph that you know
even though as lots of edges may have
lots of vertices with high degree lots
of vertices with no degree it's nice to
clean it up somewhat and so let me state
a preparatory lemma which we will not
prove but it's a similar nature to this
very easy lemma that we saw earlier but
with a bit more work originally I put a
seat over here
but no it's okay okay so the preparation
is that we're going to pass to a large
almost regular sub graph too much about
the details I'll tell you what the idea
is so for every alpha there exists
constants beta K such that for every C
and n sufficiently large every N vertex
graph G with lots of edges so see n to
the 1 plus alpha edges has a sub graph G
prime such that so I want some
properties first G prime has lots of
vertices n to the beta still lots of
vertices you do some polynomial in a net
and 2 it has still
lots of edges relative to the number of
vertices it has basically changing the
constants if I start with n to the 1
plus alpha I still have roughly number
vertices to the 1 plus alpha number of
edges it is almost regular in the sense
that the max degree of G does not differ
from its minimum degree by more than a
constant factor so so you don't have
vertices that are too small degree you
don't have vertices that are too large
degree and finally G prime is bipartite
and the two parts of this pie partition
have sizes differing by a factor and
most to so if you like think of G as a
regular bipartite graph this is a
preparation lemma we'll just make our
life a bit easier so from now on let's
treat P as a constant in our asymptotic
notation to simplify simplify the
notation so you have this graph G it's a
bipartite graph and for a pair of
vertices on one side a so there are no
adjusting a before pair of vertices I
say that this movie is light so it's not
it's not an edge but I talk about these
pairs I say that it is light if the
number of common neighbors
between of U and D is at least one and
less than she choose to so some common
neighbors are not human
and then we say that this pair is heavy
if a number of common neighbors is at
least T choose 2 so if a pair UV has
some common neighbors than we it's
either light or heavy I claim that if G
is a hey T prime so this is the one
subdivision of KT free bipartite graph
with vertex by partition a union B April
you Union B you will eventually be a
subset of 8 such that all the vertices
on the left of you degree at least Delta
and you is not too small so it's at
least four feet over Delta about it we
now think of Delta this is a min degree
so it has somewhat smaller than the
average it's basically the average
degree of your graph and be think of as
ends more or less the whole set of
vertices then the conclusion is that
there exists are you in a lot of light
pairs in the set exists vertex in many
light pairs
it's important that we assume that this
graph G is KP prime free because
otherwise you could imagine a situation
where essentially you have a complete
bipartite graph and every pair of
vertices is heavy so you don't have any
light pairs at all so having Katie Prime
free somehow allows us to fight flight
pairs so let's see the proof of this
lemma so you combine some nice ideas
that we've seen earlier in the course
namely double counting and also uses
Tehran's theorem
so first let's do a double counting
argument similar to the proof of the
kaveri shows Terron theorem where let's
count the number of k 1 choose like that
so the number of K 1 choose
like that between U and B I claim that
way to campus is to look through all the
vertices on the right side look at how
many neighbors it has and sum up the
degrees choose 2
so skipping some okay so let me I can
tell you what comes out
so by convexity we find that it is this
this quantity here and then assuming the
minimum degree condition we find that
this quantity is quite large so this is
a calculation very similar to what we
did for the proof of coverage to Rhonda
did low degree vertices in B do not
contribute much to the Sun so this this
sum is large and sums over all vertices
in B but the low degree vertices and B
they contribute very low because if we
sum over all the vertices of B with
degree less than two T then each summand
is at most two T squared which can by
the assumption of Delta is less than
half the total sum so the low degree
vertices of B do not contribute very
much to the Sun so let's look at the
higher degree vertices for the higher
degree vertices they contribute a
substantial chunk
and the most important thing here is
that among these vertices there are no T
mutually heavy okay so now among these
vertices but in you if you look at you
there are no T mutually heavy vertices
in you if you have three mutually heavy
vertices in you then what happens so if
you had he mutually heavy vertices if
you have let's say three vertices in you
they are mutually heavy each one of them
because they are heavy I can find many
common neighbors so I can build there's
paths of length two I can build another
path of length two and I don't run all
the vertices because they're all heavy
they all have at least he choose two
common neighbors so I can build the
subdivision of KT so there are no
mutually happy mutually heavy vertices
in you okay so where have we seen this
before so you have think about the
neighborhood of a vertex in V because
it's inside a neighborhood all the pairs
are either heavy or light and there are
no T mutually heavy vertices so then
Tehran's theorem tells us
that there must be many white vertices
that there are many light vertices in
this neighborhood so number of light
pairs in the neighborhood of this V yes
as at least P neighbors so else you run
out of room yes at least right so if you
think about what Tehran's term says set
a number of long edges it's at least
this quantity here which is at least the
degree of P squared so Torrens theorem
tells us that there cannot be so many
heavy pairs inside the neighborhood of a
vertex in B so there must be many light
pairs and now we sum over all vertices
and beep we obtain that you pass a lot
of light pairs we might have over
counted a little bit right because each
light pair is over countered if you only
buy a bounded number of times because
it's light
recounted by less than K choose two
times so that's a constant factor and
we're okay with that okay so that's the
conclusion for now this lemma tells us
that you have lots of light pairs in you
and what we're going to do is to keep on
shrinking this u so U is going to be a
subset of a initially let's let u be the
entire set it tells us that there's one
vertex in a with lots of night like
neighbors pick that vertex
she was neighborhood apply the lemma
again find another vertex with lots of
internal light neighbors keep on going
and then we built a large light clique
so that's the idea so we'll find that so
we'll see that if this Delta is bigger
than basically the quantity claimed in
the theorem over sufficiently large C
then there exists the sequence u 1 u 2 u
3 so on all the way to UT and the
sequence of vertices V 1 V 2 V T so such
that initially I take a and the idea is
initial V I take V 1 to be whatever
comes out of that lemma and I want the
property that all of the V I V J's are
light and to X I know three of these
beasts have a common neighbor and I
think once you have these two properties
that you can find your click subdivision
you find these T like vertices so if you
have u 1 V 2 V 3 before you have these
like vertices and I can build a click
subdivision from these light vertices
because they're light they have at least
one common neighbor for each pair and
just keep building them build these
common neighbors well you should be
somewhat worried that I end up using the
same vertex twice but of course that
should not be a worry if is guarantee
that no three of them have a common
neighbor they cannot collapse you cannot
have two vertices end up being the same
otherwise I would violate property B
so these two properties alone allow you
to build a KP subdivision but how do we
find this sequence so we build it
intuitively using that lemma you start
with one vertex guarantee by that lemma
you look at this neighborhood you pick
another vertex guaranteed by the lemma
you look at this neighborhood and so on
and you build the sequence of light the
light neighborhood yeah so we're not in
the graph anymore so everything's inside
a everything is inside so let me finish
off the list of properties and we're
almost there third property I want is
that when I do this operation I do not
reduce my space of possibilities by too
much namely that the size of U does not
go down to substantially and that's
guaranteed by the level and four is that
basically this picture over here VI is
light to all of you i plus one
so I claim that you can find the
sequence satisfying these properties and
the reason is that you will repeatedly
apply the lemma so repeatedly apply
lemma the lemma doesn't address this
part about triple vertices having common
neighbors but I think that's actually
not so hard to deal with because if you
think about how many vertices how many
possibilities this restriction
illuminates so big only eliminates at
each step key choose two because this is
coming from the like restriction times I
knows another P choose 2 and this comes
the first one comes from pairs
eliminates almost this many times the
max degree
you